la solidarité des français une nouvelle
fois au rendez-vous le téléthon
enregistré un record de promesses de
dons pour cette 20e édition retransmise
sur france télévisions avec plus de 101
millions d'euros récoltés pour financer
les multiples programmes de recherche
contre les myopathies janvier fisac et
il était deux heures du matin dimanche
et l'espoir s'est inscrit en neuf sud va
plus de 101 millions d'euros après
trente deux heures une étrange alchimie
mélangeant la féerie du spectacle et la
générosité de millions de personnes
comme le petit les hommes
c'est un enfant de neuf ans et demi il a
décidé d'organiser un aussi plateau de
football dans notre village de 2000
habitants qui est saint michel sur
meurthe dans les vosges et il a récolté
592 euros de gains et ça pourra gamin
ressources et bien faute deux heures de
folie mais aussi 32 heures d'émotion
comme celle de la présidente de l'afm
qui a perdu un enfant et se bat pour
sauver les eaux le défi majeur c'est de
trouver le traitement pour demain le
traitement pour adrien et pour tous les
enfants qui sont là ce soir
merci d'être à nos côtés et émotion
encore avec elodie qui a su nous faire
sourire éplorée à la fois aux malades
mis au pas tous comme ça ne fait pas
plaisir des cours aux enfants ça pour
qu'on n'est pas très gentilles à s'auto
place avant là parce que je pourrais
avoir leur ancien de toute notre donc ce
centre est caché un accord central
sarlat rossia alors n'oubliez pour le 36
il a raison disent où vous pouvez encore
appelé pendant une semaine